c'est vraiment à télécharger
l'application c'est tellement simple
dans l'univers numérique les
influenceurs sont omniprésents ils sont
suivis par des milliers de gens surtout
des jeunes souvent dans leur publication
se glisse des publicités alimentaires
des aliments qui ne sont pas toujours
sains
effectivement que c'est très présent le
domaine de la nourriture sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est un des domaines qui est le
plus plus présent ici à l'agence Clark
influence Catherine recherche sur
différentes plateformes l'influenceur
qui peut bien représenter une marque on
s'est spécialise vraiment dans marketing
d'influence dans toute campagne
marketing qu'on va faire en fait va
mettre un influenceur au coeur de cette
campagne là si on est capable de voir le
pourcentage d'hommes versus de femmes
qui suivent l'influenceurs et les
tranches d'âge par sexe donc dans le cas
présent on aurait deux points 91% de son
histoire qui serait des femmes âgées de
13 à 17 ans chaque entreprise qui vient
vers nous est-ce qu'on appelle un Brive
donc nous communique certains détails
par exemple un public cible à approcher
des messages clés et le type de produit
à mettre de l'avant et ensuite c'est à
notre tour de trouver les inflenseurs
qui respectent ces critères là je vous
confirme que le beyon meat de chez IW et
incroyable on veut que ce soit organique
qu'il veuille en parler mais qui
l'utilise aussi dans son quotidien c'est
difficile pour un enfant de reconnaître
c'est une publicité c'est même difficile
des fois pour un ado de dire ah oui ça
c'est un influenceur qui essaie de me
vendre un produit à cause des fois ça
peut être très subtil c'est vraiment
divertissement et marketing comme
combiné ensemble Monique Podvin Kent et
chercheuse en santé publique selon les
études tout le marketing alimentaire à
une incidence sur la santé des jeunes
alors on sait que en ce moment que les
enfants à peu près 30% des enfants sauf
dans le bon coin ou d'obésité au Canada
en général leur consommation d'aliments
ultra transformés et très très élevé
puis on sait que le marketing
alimentaire a un impact sur leur
préférence alimentaire alors les enfants
préfèrent manger les produits qu'ils
voient à la télé sur l'Internet ça peut
certainement penser le comportement donc
à partir de là il y a de la législation
qui est mis en place par le cône
canadien de la publicité mais il y a
aussi les plateformes qui mènent la
législation en place d'eux-mêmes pour
faire attention aux répercussions que ça
pourrait avoir sur l'audience
au Québec une loi interdit toute forme
de publicité aux enfants de moins de 13
ans on a pu estimer qu'il voit à peu
près 1500 pubs alimentaires par année
sur les médias sociaux mais pour les
adolescents qui passent beaucoup plus de
temps sur les médias sociaux c'était
plus de 9000 publicités alimentaires par
année alors ça c'est beaucoup beaucoup
de publicité par exemple ici on a une
influenceur qui fait de la promotion
pour une chaîne de restauration rapide
très connue où ça commence ici donc on
la voit magazine son café à la main
faire son arbre de Noël avec son café et
évidemment elle s'est rendu en
restaurant pour acheter du café avant de
passer à ses activités et elle se
termine avec la mention pub donc on
comprend très clairement que c'est une
publicité que c'est de la promotion pour
pas créer de confusion auprès de son
auditoire
les influenceurs doivent donc afficher
et inscrire le mot publicité ou
collaboration s'ils sont rémunérés ou
s'il reçoivent un colis promotionnel
il suffit de slot pour se croire en été
ici on a une vidéo dans la plateforme
TikTok elle fait la promotion d'extra
slush on regarde ici encore une fois le
hashtag pub donc on comprend que c'est
une publicité
parfois il n'y a pas de produit
alimentaire on utilise le marketing de
marque comme des logos des mascottes des
vêtements ça consiste à mettre de
l'avant non pas un produit mais un
élément distinctif de la marque comme
par exemple un logo un slogan une
mascotte et ces problématiques parce que
ça permet de créer un lien d'affection
entre la marque l'enfant et le produit
qui va perdurer ensuite à l'âge adulte
on sent vraiment interpellé par cette
personne là on sent vraiment que c'est
notre ami qui fait partie de notre
famille et on a le goût de le suivre on
a le goût de l'écouter on sent vraiment
quand il y a un conseil bien que ça
vient de quelqu'un qu'on connaît et donc
on est plus enclin à vouloir le suivre
pour les jeunes c'est il adore ça que
c'est leur idoles puis quand ces gens-là
commencent à promouvoir des produits et
puis il nous l'époque ils sont en train
de promouvoir des produits
ils prennent un peu avantage des enfants
ils prennent avantage des adolescents
outre les influenceurs d'autres
stratégies sont utilisées par les
compagnies pour rejoindre les jeunes
comme ici avec ce jeu non seulement les
enfants
voient une publicité mais sont même
appelés à interagir avec la marque qui
rentre dans l'univers et joue avec les
éléments de la marque Marie-Jeanne de la
Coalition Poids surveille l'industrie il
y en a porté plainte contre ce jeu là de
timmorton qui est un jeu dans lequel les
enfants sont invités à se promener dans
un univers super ludique dans lequel on
voit beaucoup d'images de marques de Tim
Hortons de produits Tim Hortons comme
les Bains selon nous ça convient la loi
québécoise en ce moment qui interdit la
publicité aux enfants
Tim Horton affirme ne pas avoir eu
connaissance de la plainte jusqu'à
maintenant
en ce moment à la Chambre des communes
fédérales il y a un projet de loi puis
ce projet de loi-là propose de
restreindre le marketing alimentaire qui
est destiné aux enfants dans toutes
sortes de différentes médias puis on
espère que dans la prochaine année que
c'est un projet de loi qui va devenir
une loi le lobby de l'industrie
alimentaire est très très fort donc si
l'industrie alimentaire dépense autant
en marketing alimentaire auprès des
enfants c'est parce que ça marche et ils
ont pas avantage évidemment à ce que la
publicité soit encore triste à la télé
il y a des limites à la télé on peut
dire OK dans une période de 30 minutes
on peut juste mettre tant de publicité
mais à l'Internet il y a pas de limite
comme ça
il y aura pas le choix effectivement
d'avoir des lois qui sont qui soient
mises en place et plus strict mieux
encadré en fait les influenceurs dans
leur travail parce qu'il y en a qui
naissent tous les jours en France
récemment il y a eu plusieurs offensives
justement pour encadrer ce métier là
parce qu'aujourd'hui oui il y en a qui
vivent de ça ça devient un métier et au
Québec on n'est pas encore rendu là mais
c'est sur la table il y a des
discussions qui existent
en ce moment au Canada c'est la moitié
de l'assiette des enfants et des
adolescents qui sont des aliments et des
boissons ultra transformées donc c'est
très préoccupant donc les maladies
chroniques comme le diabète de type 2 ou
l'hypertension artérielle c'est des
maladies qui autrefois étaient seulement
diagnostiqués chez les adultes et de
plus en plus on les voit apparaître des
enfants alors c'est vraiment au
gouvernement de réglementé de changer
l'environnement il faut vraiment
protéger les enfants c'est quelque chose
qui est important dans notre société il
faut vraiment mettre les enfants en
priorité
[Musique]